-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
We are here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Studio 6A in New York City.
It feels good.
Thank you so much for watching.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, I think it's fair
to say that right now
America is at a crossroads.
It doesn't get much bigger
than this.
So we begin tonight
with our top story.
-Get excited because McDonald's
is bringing back the McRib.
-That's right.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Americans were like,
"Finally, a glimmer of hope
in the barren wasteland
that's been 2020."
[ Laughter ]
When he heard about it,
Trump dropped out of the race
and said, "I'm done.
Clearly, I've
'made America great again.'
The McRib."
[ Laughter ]
Somehow you know
2020 will wrap up
with the McRib being the cure
for COVID.
You know that, right?
[ Laughter ]
In other less exciting news, the
election is just four days away.
And Trump is busy campaigning,
but I saw a new poll
that found that nearly 60%
of Americans disapprove
of Trump holding large rallies
during the pandemic.
So, not only are the rallies
dangerous,
they're also unpopular.
They're basically the kid
in high school
who played with
the Bunsen burners.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, if you want to do
something dangerous
and unpopular, go to your local
Blimpie and order the tuna.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump is still
holding rallies,
including one yesterday
in Tampa,
but it didn't go quite
as planned, watch this.
-Just two days after
President Trump's rally
in Omaha, Nebraska,
sent several supporters
to the hospital
for being too cold,
his rally in Tampa, Florida,
yesterday sent even more
to the hospital
for being too hot.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't worry, Trump had
everyone cool off
by blowing
in each other's faces.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Trump said we are only
seeing more cases of heatstroke
because we have
the most testing.
[ Laughter ]
Years from now, Trump supporters
will be reminiscing
about these rallies like
they're old concerts.
Like, "Were you at the
hypothermia rally?"
"Nah, I caught him on the
heatstroke leg of the tour."
Yeah, it was so hot in Tampa,
a fire truck --
this is real -- actually
sprayed water over the crowd.
But Trump didn't seem to know
what was happening.
Check out what he said.
-Look at that. Oh, are they
doing that on purpose?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Are they friend or foe?
It felt good.
I felt water on my face,
I said, where the hell
is that coming from from?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They may be doing that
on purpose.
Let's find out if they're
friend or foe.
And if they are foe, let's take
care of those son of a bitches.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump's like, "Friend or foe,
either way,
let's turn this into
a wet T-shirt contest.
Come on!
Those sons of bitches."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, people were packed tightly
in unsanitary conditions
and hosed down with water.
It's good to know his supporters
are being treated
like circus elephants.
[ Laughter ]
And get this, with long waits
at the polls,
I heard you can hire
someone to stand in line
and hold your place.
And for an extra $50
on election night,
they'll scream into
a pillow for you.
[ Laughter ]
You do that for voters,
you're patriotic.
You do that at Disney, you're
dragged through Toontown
while they throw turkey legs
at you.
"Shame! Shame!"
[ Laughter ]
You guys, Halloween is tomorrow
and everyone has plans,
and some notable people
in Washington
also have something going on.
I'll show you what I mean.
For example,
Mike Pence plans to
hand trick-or-treaters
his favorite hard candy,
ice cubes.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Donald Trump, Jr.,
plans to inhale
a bunch of Pixy Stix
and go rant on Fox News.
-The media runs right away.
It's Russian disinformation.
There's literally zero evidence
that it's Russian
disinformation.
[ Laughter ]
-Steve Mnuchin plans to
tell kids for the last time,
"I'm not dressed as McLovin."
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani plans to
spend a quiet night at home
tucking in his shirt.
That's...interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Wilbur Ross plans to slowly
suck on a Werther's Original
until he nods off.
[ Laughter ]
That's kind of cute. Yeah.
I'm not sure about this --
Joe Biden plans to bore
trick-or-treaters
with long story about
how his friend Ron Caramel
invented the candy apple.
[ Laughter ]
And finally President Trump
plans to
smile through a window
and be a human jack-o'-lantern.
Oh, well I hope
they all have fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I hope they have a good time,
it's Halloween.
Well, let's change gears,
I heard soon you'll be able
to buy a brand new kind of milk.
Take a look.
-Nestle is coming out with
Cinna-toast Crunch-flavored
milk, aka "Cinnamilk."
The new flavored milk tastes
like a epic combination
of cinnamon and sugar
deliciousness,
with hints of toasted cereal
in every sip.
[ Light laughter ]
-Cows --
cows heard and were like,
"I didn't realize what we did
wasn't enough for you."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
here's a weird story,
a food writer in Georgia
just created a restaurant
on her front porch
for chipmunks.
Take a look.
-Yeah. Right now,
her kids are like,
"Okay, we need to talk
about Mom."